well there are even more serious
concerns tonight among mainstream
Democrats about whether there's any way
to stop Democratic Socialist Bernie
Sanders from securing the party's
presidential nomination
Sanders buried the competition in the
Nevada caucuses Saturday and he's now
threatening to upset Joe Biden in the
state the former vice president has
called his firewall correspondent Peter
Doocy reports tonight from Charleston
South Carolina for the 12,000 Texans
turned out to see Bernie Sanders in
Austin last night why God there are a
lot of people here with two wins in a
row under his belt Sanders is starting
to shine a light on what it means to be
a Democratic Socialist
we're very opposed to the authoritarian
nature of Cupid you know you got it's
unfair to simply say everything was bad
you know when Fidel Castro came into
office you know what he did he had a
massive literacy program is that a bad
thing
even though Fidel Castro did he Sanders
leads the Real Clear Politics average of
polls by double digits ahead of Joe
Biden Michael Bloomberg and Elizabeth
Warren that is what the party will
decide we can do this fight it is still
confident after finishing fourth fifth
and second so far but first South
Carolina where a recent Winthrop poll
finds Biden leading Sanders and Tom
Steyer in third I don't sell Carolina's
most prominent elected Democrat
congressman james Clyburn is preparing
to endorse Biden ahead of a contest the
candidate has suggested is critical
South Carolina though was your fireball
you said in my firewall I've never seen
he did say it though this month I think
I have a real fire wall in South
Carolina Pete Budaj edge is hoping to
recapture some of the magic that helped
him win Iowa and Amy Klobuchar has no
plans to drop out when you actually look
at the vote I am the third highest vote
getter in this field the highest vote
getter is Sanders and he's soaking it
all up
well you know I am the US senator and I
got a big ego and I appreciate the
Bernie but it ain't Bernie it is us
[Applause]
and this is an open primary which means
Republicans could go and vote for
Democrats on Saturday if they want to
but I just spoke to a very plugged in
Republican operative here in South
Carolina who said that there is no
organized effort to try to get
Republicans to pick the president's
opponent for now Shannon all right we'll
stay tuned Peter Doocy thank you